Hello.
Welcome back.
We're welcome to Holocure.
This is my, what, third time playing this game on stream?
I think.
I was just watching Astro Vibe Live.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Josh, thanks for the 10k gift.
Thank you.
Today is going to be a bit of a shorter stream because I have a concert later tonight that I will be doing.
Off-Kai off-season.
I'm going to be on a boat.
And I want to... my voice is a little raspy today.
I don't know if it's because I haven't talked much.
I gotta warm it up.
A boat.
Oh my goodness, someone's loud outside.
Too much yapping.
I can't stop yapping.
More throat drops.
I have a... see, you can hear it, right?
I have some... actually, do I have any cough drops in here?
Let me check.
Kittens, are you guys okay?
Not you guys.
I'm not calling you guys my kittens.
I'm talking about actual cats.
Don't get it twisted.
Oh, I do have some.
Oh, I have... oh good, I have a throat direct.
One second.
Why is she calling us kittens?
Not you!
Oh my god.
I can't look at you right now.
I started the second book last night in the Minotaur Milking Farm series.
And the next book is about a lady and she's too horny to think.
That's literally the first line in the book.
She goes, I'm too horny to think.
And I'm like, relatable.
But then she says...
She says...
She goes on like some sort of...
She becomes like an exhibitionist because the Mothman looks at her through her window.
Actually, I'm going to actually use the actual cough drop.
Yeah.
So...
I was listening to this one series.
Well, not really a series, but this is one author.
Oh, for those who don't know, I listen to like romance novels while I'm going to sleep.
They just...
Drone on, you know?
And they're usually very silly.
But...
There was one recently.
This one lady...
Is like obsessed with like Mafia.
I don't...
I've never heard this term before.
But she's obsessed with Mafia.
And also the Mafia guy having a surprise baby.
So...
And so...
Here, let me just read you...
These are a handful of her books.
Surprise Bratva Daddy.
What is a Bratva?
That's like a Mafia guy, right?
Surprise Bratva Daddy.
Arranged Mafia Daddy.
The Mafia Surprise Baby.
Triplets for the Bratva.
Surprise Baby for the Bratva Voss.
Baby for the Bratva.
I'm seeing a pattern.
Yeah, Bella King is like very specific about what she likes.
She's like, I like mafias and I like surprise babies.
Russian mob fetishes.
It's Russian mob slash gang.
I see.
Okay.
No, I'm not paying for this.
I got it from my library.
Thank you.
I'm supporting the local arts.
Oh.
No, sorry.
The Mafia babies are from YouTube.
Anyway.
Welcome.
Back to Holocure.
I've been playing...
I've been trying to farm a lot of coins off stream.
Nico.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Sounds more like smut than romance.
Sorry, I wouldn't have talked about this if I hadn't seen Moe Mothman.
Also, welcome back to membership, Moe Mothman.
So, I've been farming a little bit.
I haven't done any more character gacha, but mostly I've just been like using Risu and like eating money.
So I have like some upgrades.
Oh.
I have some upgrades.
And then I've gotten some more upgrades.
So.
Mm, mm, mm, mm.
Did I do the Russian two wands in those?
Oh.
A lot of times.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
The only YouTuber I watch that talks about NSFW makes me feel like I'm hearing the weirdest nerd.
Not NSFW.
What do you mean?
Maybe it's because...
I'm a nerd.
We're little freaks.
I don't know.
I got too addicted to fishing.
I haven't fished.
I haven't fished because I'm scared of becoming addicted to the fishing.
You know?
Ray?
What am I reading?
Right?
Ray?
Raylist?
Thank you for the Ray.
Thank you.
Hello.
Hi, Raylist.
I'm in phantom.
I'm a ghost mode.
Hello, Mint and Chat.
Finally gathered my confidence to say hi.
Hello.
Thank you for saying hi.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Ducky, I see you too.
Thanks for the gifted.
Paperbacks, thanks for the five.
Gifted.
Hello.
I'm playing Holocure.
I'm still a bit of a Holocure newbie.
There's a...
They've been posting stuff about...
about a new update.
I don't know when the new update's gonna... supposed to be, but today my goal is to...
I still haven't...
Here.
I'm just gonna...
I'm not gonna actually play, but I have not beat the Halloween castle yet.
It's Halloween time.
I must beat Halloween castle.
I've just been kind of farming in the holo office over and over again, so expect it around November.
Okay.
Awesome.
That gives me plenty of time.
Thank you devs for your hard work.
Thank you.
So...
Um...
It's Halloween.
Max your speed for that one.
For this?
Yeah.
I've...
I tried it a couple times and I struggled.
I don't remember how...
I think I...
I almost beat it one time, but I have not even gotten to the last boss yet.
I haven't even gotten to 20 minutes.
So...
Okay.
Hmm.
That's my goal today.
Yeah.
Casey!
Thanks for the vibe.
Gifted!
So vital!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
But um...
Let's buy some upgrades.
I'll...
I've been...
I've been buying stuff.
A little bit, you know.
Oh!
Hi.
Bootaro.
Hi, do you want out swords?
No, thanks.
This is why you came to me.
Hey!
It's just your birthday?
I want to admit that I listened to this old birthday song you and your friend sang for me one time.
Can I get a... wait... I listened to this old...
That's so sweet!
Can I get a happy yippie?
Happy yippie, congratulations Happy yippie with salutations Happy yippie, may your sky stay blue Happy yippie to you Happy birthday Paige!
Happy happy birthday, happy birthday to you Happy happy birthday from one of my oldest fans ever Not just in age, but it's how long you've been watching me Thank you for the super chat!
Let's see, what should I get?
What should I get?
I have a bit of money, so...
Not just their age Thanks, see you later I just bit my...
I just bit my cheek I'll see you there!
Yippie!
Um...
Money upgrades, so true!
Aww...
Butaro!
Look how cute you are!
Do you want out?
Let me let my cat out real quick Because he's got... I don't want to get in the middle of a match And then he gets sad, you know?
One second!
One second...
He protested!
I tried kicking him out and he was just like...
Meow!
He protested!
We laugh at the elderly Just like Mitsoshi mikes the class That's so true!
Oh my gosh, I was...
Well, it wasn't...
I was watching Red Letter Media last night too I gotta watch that...
That Civ...
Whatever...
Parkour thing But it's like long Instead, last night I watched Digital Circus But that's like 30 minutes That's different I can watch 30 minutes I can't watch like an hour and a half Were you watching The Puppet Master?
I was!
Parkour Civilization...
Yeah, I wonder why everybody keeps talking about it I need to know about the beef Finally I'm able to see it stream live!
Hello Simon!
Do you have everyone unlocked?
I don't I actually don't I'm missing Reine?
Muna?
I think that's Mikochi?
Zeira?
Oh, Kobo?
I can always miss Kobo Choco-sensei?
Shion?
Is that Ayame?
And then Aqua
Yeah So I still have a few people Maybe I should...
I know, Kobo is stealthy back there
Yeah...
We're all missing Aqua
Who do you find most enjoyable to play so far?
That's a great question!
Well, since I've been mostly just trying to farm money I've been using Risu a lot a lot I've tried...
I'll be honest Like a lot of people I have not played Like...
You can see Um...
Wait, what does that mean?
Why is there like a...
A little trophy down here for some?
I've been...
Number of wins?
Oh, I think it's just regular...
It doesn't count endless then, right?
Because...
I do...
I did endless with Risu a lot So...
I have done Sana But like I said...
I've been mostly just playing...
With Risu because I've just been farming So...
And...
I wanted to like maybe try new people...
On...
Stream...
But it probably is best to like...
Get their fandom up and stuff I don't know...
I was trying to like farm and unlock a bunch of stuff...
Off stream so that you know...
On stream I can do like the new things and...
Stuff like that...
So...
Maybe...
Maybe I should try unlocking everybody else though...
Let's see if I can unlock everybody else...
Wait...
Who was I missing?
Okay...
Shop...
Gacha time...
That was so easy...
Easy game...
Okay...
Kobo...
Zeta...!
In a row!
Oh!
Okay...
Come on...
Kobo...
5 Zeta...
What is this luck?
What is this gacha luck?
Oh my god...
What?
I don't wanna Spark...
But I don't want to waste all my money.
Oh my god, what is happening?
Who is hacking my game?
Fine.
I don't want to do a ten pull.
I don't want to waste all my money.
Okay.
Alright, we need Renne.
Renne, first try.
Wait, okay, let me do...
We'll do like five.
Yeah, we'll do like a five pull.
Okay,
this is the one.
This is the one!
Oh gosh, is my throat going to be okay for the night?
I'm going to have to rest more than I thought.
Okay, no screaming today guys.
No screaming.
Just normal, normal.
Okay, okay, okay.
Muna, Muna.
We need Muna.
First try.
Lo-fi.
Let's see, who else joined in?
Oh my gosh, it's looking so full now!
Mika.
Thanks for the ten gifts!
Takama, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
ID complete, baby.
Okay, this one I'm actually going to do... Oh, wait, I already bought it.
We're going to do a five.
Five pull after.
Yeah.
I love how I had no confidence to even get her on the first try.
Yippee!
Okay.
We got her.
Mikochi.
No confidence.
I think I have all of Gen 1.
It's a lot of Gen 2 we don't have.
Let's do a five pull and see if we just grab them all in one go.
Ta-da!
Oh!
All
I need is Choco-sensei!
Wait, actually?
Yeah!
Yo!
That was so good!
Even the alphas.
That was... Okay, finally.
My luck.
My luck turns around.
Okay, first try.
Who's missing?
Just Choco.
Oh, we got regular!
Aqua.
So cute.
Aqua again!
Aqua town.
That explains why your Astro Bot gacha luck was so bad.
No!
My luck is good.
Right?
Oh!
I got the new outfit!
Choco-sensei, now!
Now!
Shubai!
Okay, I'll do five again.
And this is the last one we'll do.
I want the other outfit.
Yippee!
Unlock all characters.
Yay!
Now we have everybody.
Oh my gosh, my screen is so full!
It's so beautiful!
Wow!
No!
Oh gosh, I just want to keep farming for more money.
But let's go back and let's do some upgrades.
Um...
Oh, that's right.
I wish I had this last run.
Because I was just playing.
And I wanted to do the super collab with the Lamy Water.
But I didn't get the sake.
But I still beat it.
So, you know.
It's my birthday today.
And I just wanted to say thanks for all the happiness you've brought to all of us.
Even though I can't watch live much anymore.
The VODs are still top tier sleep material.
Gomi!
Thank you!
Happy birthday, Gomi!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Moeru Gomi.
Happy birthday.
Thanks for the break.
I was wondering what kind of game you'd want if someone made a fan game.
Oh.
I can't think of ideas.
That aside...
I just want to say...
Thanks for being a red light that helped me get through rough times.
What?
If I had a fan game...
Horror game?
A scary game?
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe a horror game.
Minto, collect 8 pages.
I'm not sure.
Poran!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Stealth scary game?
Stealth is already a horror game to me.
Let's see.
What do I want to level up?
Some people were saying speed.
I'll do speed.
Let's see.
More money.
More problems.
Money?
Money is good.
Ghostly stealth infiltration game.
Haunt slash possess people.
The game writes itself?
That's so true.
Skills up?
Increase the damage of skill.
Yeah, money does speed up the grind.
That's so true.
Right now we're not going to grind so much though.
We're going to try new stuff today.
Did you increase the spawn rates?
No, I didn't do anything like that because I am still so new to the game.
I'm just a baby.
I got all of my haste.
So, haste is maxed.
You got them all for now.
What do you mean?
Yeah, I want to try and beat stage three today.
So, that's why I keep like looking at attack.
But, I'm going to do more money.
Okay, let's do a skill because it's cheap.
Critical hit is good for the price.
It is very good for the price.
Yeah.
Okay.
Psychological more...
You have ghost investigating your own death?
What the hell, that actually sounds so interesting.
You cooked?
I always gravitate the money so I could get the rest faster.
The money won't help us.
Sorry.
Fine.
Do I want to do a special cooldown?
Or crit?
I'll do crit.
I was so close to be able to do both.
That is kind of like ghost trick, isn't it?
What's it called?
The detective gets more insane stuff?
That's not so much.
Let's see.
Okay, who do I have that's like a decent... that I've pulled a lot?
Zayda?
G-Rig 7!
That's crazy.
Oh my god, she has a pistol!
It is I, chat.
Remember to ignore the game.
Just look at the chat to know where to move, when to ult, and why you died.
Thank you, Paul.
Thank you for the reminder.
Is Zayda...
Would she be good at this?
Turn invisible for 8 seconds.
While invisible, Zayda does not take damage and all targets stop moving towards...
Okay, I'm ulting?
I'm ulting right now?
I'm ulting?
I just ulted?
I died.
Why did I die, chat?
Zayda very good but maybe not for babies.
I'm just a baby.
She's fun but kind of difficult.
I heard that like Okayu is very... where is she?
Oh, Okayu is really difficult too.
Like the onigiri in an arc.
Seems kind of hard to manage.
You've been dead the whole time!
Sui-chan is great if you get axe.
Who would be good for the third stage?
Hmm...
Ayame or she?
Slash is twice in front.
Hmm...
Iris is a tank?
Oh, I have her at 5 too!
Fauna is strong.
I do like playing with Fauna.
You can't die with Fauna.
Need a Metal Gear style game?
But it's just meant haunting a library to read their romance songs?
Sneaking by security.
I have not...
I've played with Iris.
I do not...
When did I play...
When did I beat a game with Iris?
Honestly, I don't remember playing with her at all.
Am I crazy?
I can't decide!
Crazy?
I was crazy once.
Let's try Iris.
Oh, uh...
Okay, I'm just gonna do stage mode.
Since I haven't beaten it.
So let's try.
Let's go!
Oh, I do remember a little bit, maybe.
Maybe I'm crazy.
Oh,
there's so many little things.
Um...
Mum, mum, mum.
Hi, Iris.
It's Iris.
Magister, welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you!
I know I am.
I know I am, but what am I?
Wait, what are you?
I made a video for you as your birthday present.
I posted it on Twitter during your birthday.
Which you didn't see, but I'm at least happy that I sang for you.
And that many people praised me.
Once again, happy birthday, my dear.
Thanks, Raiden!
Wait.
I've still been going through the hashtag.
So if I haven't seen it yet, I will get to it.
I mean, I've been...
I've been going through it.
Hope Soda's super good.
It is on theme.
It is very much on theme.
Did you like Jerma's message?
Yeah.
That was...
So Critical Hit is important with...
With Iris.
Is that what I'm getting from her?
Oh my god.
Oh gosh.
You ever have a cough drop and then you take a sip of drink?
Cold drink?
Okay.
Hope Soda.
Let's try it.
I'll just have it in my arsenal.
And again, I'm not going to be focusing on a lot of coin stuff right now.
I'm just...
I'm focusing on survival.
Oh, half demon.
These are all skills.
So I can...
They'll...
They'll come to me eventually.
Anyway, so...
This is survival round.
Survival round.
Oh, and I have like...
You know, I've...
I've unlocked some more...
Sorry, you can't...
My head...
My big old head's blocking some stuff.
But...
Like, I've gotten some more super collab stuff.
So I've been...
Unlocking things.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, isn't glow stick an idol song, something?
Yeah.
And then you get the Idol costume.
And then it becomes big.
I don't know what I want to go for yet, though.
I don't know what I want to go for yet.
I haven't decided.
Hot tone.
Yes, you are.
I'm not kidding.
I've tried the plushy before, but I don't think... When I've used it, I haven't had like a...
I feel like it's probably good with like an uber sheep kind of something going on.
Buddy!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Idle song.
Paragon, paragon.
It's great with a healer like Fauna.
Let's do half angel since we have half...
We have a half demon.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'll take that.
I love knockback.
Not just in the stamp, but like I love knockback.
What would your ult be if you were in this?
Oh!
I don't know.
Hmm.
I don't... What would my ult be?
I'm so sorry for being late.
Happy birthday!
Oh, thank you, Magister!
You saucy little maid.
Ectoplasm, maybe... Yeah, maybe I like...
Maybe I like explode ectoplasm or something.
And it pushes back everything around me.
Ectoplasm, busting, busting attack.
I'm busting.
Yeah.
Dude, let's increase our haste a little bit.
At this stage, I always get stuck on these dang...
Dang seeds.
Perish!
Increase soda intake.
Also, sorry if I don't listen to chat so much.
I've been just trying to like...
Since I've been playing so much on my own, I've been trying to like learn more stuff.
Um, you know.
How much time will you spend at the upcoming USADA casino?
I swear, if they put in blackjack, it's over for me.
It's over for me.
If they put in blackjack, you guys, I'm never leaving.
I swear.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm scared for me.
Do your thing.
Thank you.
I might, of course I'll...
Of course I'll probably ask for help in certain stuff.
Sometimes.
But...
Let's collect.
Collect our riches.
There is blackjack?
K, don't say that!
K, K, don't say that.
K, don't do that.
K, don't say that.
Don't say that to me.
No.
No, seriously.
Don't lie to me.
Don't be like that.
Don't get my hopes up.
And also...
Don't do this.
K, do you want to create a monster?
We gotta go.
You guys, I have a philosophy in blackjack.
It's called all in, baby.
And it's foolproof.
It's foolproof!
More soda.
Oh!
I was looking at...
Actually, I've never used the Peaky, Peaky, Peamon.
But wouldn't it be good?
Because Iris...
Like, her healing...
Well, I guess this doesn't heal you, technically.
It just gains 15 max HP.
I love how there's Peaky, Peaky, Peamon is weak and Peaky, Peaky, Peamon is really strong literally right next to each other.
The duality of chat once again.
Oh, it's great with a certain super collab.
It's really good if you're super focused on health.
For now, I...
I will leave it for now.
Again, I mean, survival is focused on health, but...
Ah...
Koro-san was sad when chat told her it was weak.
No!
You know you want blacksmith, I do.
But we'll keep going with the soda.
One thing I also really love to pick up, this might be controversial, I don't know, you guys can tell me, is the...
is the limiter.
Oh my gosh, I did not even see that.
I like picking up the limiter real much, cause it...
Oh my goodness.
Wow!
My goodness!
Controversial, yeah.
I know, I had a feeling it would be.
I had a feeling it would be.
But then, you know, you get like a kind of build where like...
It's...
Like you just stand in the middle, and then you just... Oh no, not this guy.
Hey!
Quit it!
Quit healing!
Okay.
Oh wait!
Oh no, super chat...
No!
Guys, this is not...
This is not a coin run!
Everybody!
This is...
This is... This... Stop!
Money!
We need to survive!
I'm greedy.
I'm too greedy!
I'm too greedy.
Big money.
Everybody drop money.
Drop money.
Right now.
Who are these little people, guys?
Oh no, guys, I...
Never mind, I lost it.
But money.
Someone said super chat time.
No!
Yeah!
What happened?
The greed.
I'm so cool, bro!
Excited for your birthday!
God, that was crazy.
Okay.
Anyway.
That was just a practice run.
That was just a practice run, everybody.
Just a little bit of a silly...
Practice run.
Right, everyone!
Right, everyone.
Okay, dropping my... Oh, no.
I didn't make it in time.
I really like nightly milk.
Cuz it like...
It does so much.
It increases attack size.
It makes the combat...
The knockback, I mean.
And everything like...
I think the milk is pretty good.
Milk in time.
Two!
Thank you!
Did you hear that a lot of people are speculating that a new Ace Combat might release soon?
What do you mean by that?
I don't really do the credit cards so much.
Because...
I don't really do the credit cards so much because...
I don't know.
Maybe I'm just lucky.
Usually my stuff is already enchanted.
So like...
I don't know.
I know it makes the anvils increase more, which is nice.
But...
I don't know.
Oh, no.
You said the secret word.
You summoned Nan.
Nan, get in here.
Oh, there he is.
Hahaha.
It goes well with Blacksmith.
That, of course, obviously.
Because I mean, you're gonna get the...
Holy moly.
You're gonna...
Oh, I maybe should have gone...
Wait, no.
Gorilla's Paw loses the critical crit, right?
It makes your attack stronger, but it makes your crit sad.
So...
No, not for Iris.
Maybe.
Oh!
Ouch!
I got stuck on the wall.
Please...
Please stop it.
Go away.
Gimme burger.
This one's in...
Hmm...
This wall in particular always looks like a little area to walk through, so...
Get cabedoned.
Pina Colada!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Let's do this one since it Let's just keep focusing on that for right now.
Survival, survival, survival, everybody.
Oh!
Oh.
Um, upgrade.
I love this adorable TV model.
It's so cute.
Thank you!
Me too.
Yep.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Oh my goodness.
Magister, thank you again!
Since you like Metal Gear, you might find an interest in Ace Combat.
Sorry for confusing you.
No, I love it!
I love Ace Combat!
If you could do a Super Collab of Among Us or Goose Goose Duck with any 10 other VTubers?
Anyone I want ever?
Oh my goodness.
That's hard.
Probably just all my Oshis.
There's like no language barrier.
I do like...
Probably like...
A lot of OGs.
Probably a lot of OGs.
Like Kaguya Luna.
I don't...
You know, thinking about it...
It's like some of these...
Some older VTubers back from the heyday.
Like...
We never got to see them play like...
Kind of big collab things like that.
You know?
It's kind of weird to think about.
Like what would Kaguya Luna be like in Among Us?
Rich Evans would collab with you?
I hope so.
Oh, Himihina!
I would love to play with them too.
Actually, I would love to collab with them like in a song.
But they would like...
I would just...
I would say that, but they would sing so well.
And I would be like...
Yeah...
I would be like...
And they would be like singing so well.
Oh...
Do I want spider cooking?
Yeah, I want spider cooking.
I feel like that would be good for this.
I feel like maybe...
I might do like the uber sheep...
super collab...
going on with...
Wow!
Virgil!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you so much!
Saura!
Spider...
You get the Miko bucket and then you get...
Let's do this one too.
Let's just start grabbing some...
of my skills.
La la la...
All the bats are coming.
Here come the bats.
How...
How am I healing sometimes?
Wow!
Nice.
Oh.
Kylidos!
Back in the membership.
Thank you, Reimu.
Hakurei Reimu.
No!
Go away!
Go away, you freak!
I know that name.
Do you?
Do you know Hakurei Reimu?
Let's keep doing soda.
Even though I can't even have it.
There was like a...
Sometimes...
Actually, this past Japan trip...
For some reason, I went to so many birthday events.
For like different idols and maids and stuff.
And usually at the birthday events...
They'll have like...
A custom cocktail you can order.
But I always...
And they usually have like either a non-alcohol or an alcohol version.
And...
But I always have to tell them...
No carbonation.
I'm more of a Suika connoisseur.
Jose, welcome back!
And Musou, welcome to membership 2!
Let's see...
Horn is nice.
I really like a horn.
I do.
Okay.
Survival, everybody.
Survival.
This is all about survival.
It's all about survival this time, baby.
This is how I died before.
Oh my goodness.
No little apple.
Did I ask before what the apple...
Mascots are?
I don't recognize them.
Nice.
Let's just level up our skill.
Oh, Aki!
Yes!
Okay.
There's Aki's fans.
What do they call them?
Oh, Nozetai.
Mmm!
They're so cute!
They're little robot apples.
Is it the Japanese version?
Oh, oh my goodness.
Do I have the Japanese version on my list for Ace Combat?
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Yes?
I own it.
So...
Um...
And I believe there are like...
Translations and stuff, right?
So...
I own...
I can't remember.
I think I'm missing one Ace Combat game.
But I own...
Most of them now.
I own many.
I go to like...
What's it called?
Retro game stores.
And search.
Wow!
Oh!
No!
Let's do more spider.
Oh my goodness.
May I please get a burger?
Okay.
Does...
How does Iris self heal?
Is it just normal?
Like this shit?
Rain of spiders.
Except they're bats.
Oh, she heals on crits.
Oh, that's right!
Okay.
That's the skill that...
Okay, okay, okay.
I see, I see.
So having like a lot of enemies...
Around is good.
More chances to...
I need something that like...
Cause her attack is...
Pretty like...
Focused, you know?
Oh my goodness.
I need something that also can...
Get...
From behind, you know?
I need to...
Focus on that too.
Yeah...
I mean, I have spider cooking...
But it's not enough, obviously.
Yeah...
Oh...
I just wished for that...
And I literally got cutting board...
But...
That's not really...
It wouldn't really work for Iris, right?
You can use your ult for coverage.
Oh yeah, I forgot I had that.
For now though...
I wanna...
I wanna see if I can get like...
Maybe...
Maybe BL book...
Plus...
The axe.
What does her ult do?
Oh!
BL book!
Yeah, I don't think Iris is very bored.
Hahaha.
...
Ahem...
Limiter, my beloved.
Me too!
But...
I will go with BL book, actually.
Maybe controversial.
...
But I went with it anyway.
Maybe slightly controversial.
...
Ah!
Where are my stabs?
When am I gonna get any stabs?
...
It's good on even boing characters?
Really?
...
I don't know what...
What collabs you can get with it either.
...
Ugh...
Chill out.
Chill out, everybody.
Oh my goodness, this is not a good position to...
...be in.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
I got one.
Finally.
Board plus bomb.
...
Maybe we can try it if I get it.
Oh!
I got the...
...
Shoot.
I think I killed him.
...
I'm powerful now.
Oh!
...
We're almost...
We've almost maxed this one out.
Oh my gosh.
I keep getting stuck.
This is so bad.
...
Holy moly.
I thought I was gonna die there.
I thought I was gonna die there for sure.
...
Emulation for translation.
... Yes!
I did know that.
For the translation.
...
Don't worry.
I've looked into stuff.
...
I have.
Let's go with the BL book.
...
I'm gonna upgrade this as well.
Get this up a little bit.
BL maxing.
Yes.
...
BL book, my beloved.
Oh gosh.
...
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
We're all good.
Oh!
Money, money, money!
Knockback!
... Are you winning, Minto?
...
Chat, am I winning?
Let's collect my riches.
...
Let's go with what we've got.
Let's focus on increasing what we've got.
Winning at life?
You mean afterlife.
...
Winning at afterlife, baby.
What do you mean minus two?
I'm literally dead!
I'm not liv- There is no life!
...
I've lived my life!
And now I'm living an afterlife!
What do you want from me?
...
Why is everything that I'm trying not to get...
Oh no!
...
Oh my gosh!
I could've ulted probably there, but...
Gosh, they're fast.
...
No!
Yeah?
And I'm very skilled, okay?
What do you want from me?
...
Oh, come on.
I like how it's still stuck around.
...
What do you want from me?
I need a question and answer that has plagued me for a while.
Why are you so cute?
...
What do you...
This is not the time!
...
Oh, X a potato.
I have wanted to do...
Wait, isn't X potato?
...
No, it's not lava.
There's another one that you can do the X potato.
I've never... Obviously I've never done it before though.
...
Oh, the bomb, right?
The bomb.
I gotta focus on...
I have my BL book though.
I gotta get something with the BL book.
...
Thank you!
Thanks Elias!
...
X potato with idol song really is the best one.
But we don't have a guarantee I'll get idol song again.
...
We could get BL...
Oh, I'll do that and then...
...
Just go for bucket.
Yeah, I'm not on endless.
If I were on endless, I would probably...
Yeah....
I forgot I'm not on endless.
Oh my gosh.
Follow your heart.
It's a bucket.
...
Right now we are doing okay though.
Right now we're doing A-OK.
The axe!
Let's just focus on this.
I don't think I'll ever get to the Super Collab, but that's OK.
I even never get to the Super Collab.
Stop it!
Stop!
Stop healing!
Thank you.
Love you.
Is every pain you feel by definition a phantom pain?
I'm mental!
Phantom pain.
Gosh, I...
Kinda can't wait to play it again.
It's gonna be so funny when Mint Phantom plays...
OK.
I guess I'll... I guess I have to.
I guess I have to.
Nightly milk!
I forgot that I had that.
Oh my god, look how many more coins there are.
Yippee!
Keep it up, Mint!
Thank you!
Thanks Renegade!
Happy Halloween, everybody!
Oh my gosh, what are you looking... are you looking forward to doing anything in Halloween?
Last year!
It's so funny.
It's kinda maybe like silly for a ghost to go ghost hunting, but it's also kinda fun...
Oh my goodness.
To see...
It's funny to like see them try and be like, ghost, can you hear me?
And I'm the ghost.
But I wanna go ghost hunting.
I went last year with my friends, ghost hunting.
I wanna go again this year too.
I should've picked up the limiter.
I swear.
Or super chatto time or something.
Oh wait, I don't think I've gotten super chatto time.
What a trickster.
I know, they're like, ghost, can you hear me?
And I'm like...
Maybe?
No, I shouldn't though.
I must be responsible.
Can I get super chatto time, please?
Look how many coins there are, you guys.
Let's go.
Oh, I'm starting to get cornered a little bit.
I'm starting to get cornered a little bit.
It's okay, we can just run in circles.
We run in circles.
Wow!
My riches!
I don't think I've ever gotten greed.
Thank you for the hunker stuff!
Thank you so much.
I don't think I've ever gotten greed without having super chatto time.
So I'm like...
So it's kind of funny, because usually all the coins come to me.
You know?
Yay!
Thank you for the tech gift!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
This area is so dangerous.
Ouchy ouch!
Oh no.
Uh oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Ubersheep, baby!
Thanks for the coin!
Nice.
Alrighty.
Alright.
You and you.
Okay.
Let's collect our riches.
While we have a little bit of downtime.
And max this out.
So that we can get the uber sheep super collab.
Ouch!
Thank you.
Nice.
Oh shoot.
Yeah, getting the hang of things little by little.
I don't know everything.
I don't know all the best combinations.
Everything like that.
Little by little we get there.
I play as I play.
Stop hurling!
Stop healing!
I think I'm gonna reroll.
What?
You know what?
Everybody said the cutting board.
I'll try cutting board.
I've gotten...
What's the cutting board?
The one where it like falls down from the sky.
Flattening board.
Yeah, the bomb and the board.
The birds, the bees.
Oh my goodness.
Gosh.
How do we live?
I don't know.
We're doing good.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no.
Please.
I want to live.
Even though I'm dead.
Cutting board.
Two.
Yeah, healing saved us.
Let's see.
What do we get?
Wow, I'm not getting very lucky on these boxes.
Oh.
Ubershape.
Good, good, good, good.
The higher we get Ubershape, the sooner we can get our...
Oh, who is toho danmaku ami?
Oh, these guys.
Stop!
Stop it, stop it, stop it!
I'm not ready!
Oh!
I could get the bomb.
Hmm.
Oh yeah, I'm at 17.
Let's do this.
Let's do the... the nightly meltdown.
I don't want to deal with this anymore!
Oh my god.
Where's my mouse?
There it is.
Her healing really does go crazy.
Oh my gosh.
I say that as I'm literally dying.
It is quite good though.
Oh my god.
Don't do that.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I walked right into it.
Stop shooting at me!
Okay.
I'm gonna just keep going with Ubersheep, guys.
We're gonna try for the ultra collab.
The big collab, baby.
What's your favorite... I asked.
I was gonna say, I'm not gonna be able to read this but I'm not gonna be able to read it.
I ask you questions and I'm like, I can't read it though.
I can't read.
I was gonna say what's your favorite, like, Ultra collab, but I can't even read it so...
Don't tell me until I can read.
Where's my mouse?
There it is.
Stop.
Please.
Please!
Asakoko plus beam?
No, no, no.
These ones.
The big ones.
My ghost she can't read.
The Idol Show one?
This one?
Gorilla Pod plus Dragonfire.
I haven't gotten that one.
Fascinating.
Thank you for your information.
Please!
Live Iris!
Sounds like a disease, but it's not.
It's important.
Don't die Iris!
There we go.
That sounds way more natural.
That sounds way more natural than Live Iris.
What was I trying to upgrade?
Oh, I can't.
Okay, now...
Give me...
Give me Gold Anvil.
I guess I could have enchanted, huh?
I'm used to enchanting...
Like...
Later in the...
You know...
Yippee!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die everybody.
Sayonara world!
Actually, I'm alive.
Just kidding.
That was so close.
That was actually...
That was actually so close.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Run Iris!
Run!
Wait!
You guys, this is the furthest I've ever gotten.
A Damaku.
A Damaku!
I'm collecting my riches.
She just does a Damaku kind of similar to Ei-chan.
Okay, I probably should like...
Attack her at some point, you know?
Run Iris!
Go go go!
Guys!
Guys, I think we've got this.
Why am I talking?
Don't speak.
Minthe, you idiot!
Don't open your mouth.
Don't have confidence.
Don't speak!
Don't speak.
You're gonna jinx yourself.
And that'll be really sad.
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
Guys, we're in trouble.
Guys, we're in so much trouble.
Guys.
Guys, we're in trouble.
Oh, never mind, we're okay.
We were in trouble.
I wasn't lying.
We were definitely in trouble.
We were definitely in trouble, but it was also okay.
Dang, Iris really is tanky, isn't she?
That's kind of awesome.
The screams are so funny.
Let's go Iris!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh...
I'm just running around in circles.
We did it!
Wow.
I, I, I...
Now what do I do?
Hey Mint!
Why did you spell my name like that?
I got a raise, so here's my tax.
Please use it to improve our housing.
It's getting crowded and smelly.
Ian's curse!
Fires cursed energy in front.
On hit, there's a chance to spread another curse.
Stage 4?
Hold on, I'm just going to pick someone random.
Stage 4... is...
Wait, is there anything after stage 4?
Hard mode.
Yeah, I knew there were hard stages.
Hard stages 1 through 3.
I heard that hard stage...
3... no.
Yeah, 3.
You fight...
You fight small myth, is that true?
Shop, shop, shop, shop, shop, shop, shop, shop!
I don't have enough for money.
But, I can do...
Maybe I can just finish out crit?
Congrats on completing stage 3!
Yeah!
It was surreal watching you fight Tarantula.
Well, I have Hatchaman the next time.
Haha.
Nice.
You guys, my haste is all the way up.
Why do you guys keep saying...
Why do you guys keep saying, do more haste.
My haste is all...
I can't do anymore haste.
My haste is all the way up.
Get more haste, download more haste.
I'm downloading?
Downloading?
I got it from this place called the... the... the Senchou Bay.
Now I have a virus.
Let's see... part of me wants to just buy the cheap ones just so I can finish them.
But the cooldown is pretty good.
I can finish it.
I just want to complete stuff, you know?
It's like the completionist just makes me want to be like...
But then I can focus on other things, you know?
It will be crossed off.
It's like crossing off something on your list and you don't have to look at it anymore, you know?
Complete it!
Okay.
All I needed was one person in chat to say, complete it.
And I say, okay.
Do more haste.
Let's see.
I want the Gacha.
Let's do it in Council.
Because I feel like Fana, Mumei, Sana are like three characters that... I do.
You know?
Am I missing any?
Nope!
I got all of them.
I have all the characters.
I have not done the no movement challenge because it scares me.
I have quite a lot of achievements that I have not done.
Let's see.
Quite a bit.
What's this?
Clear stage without having any character skills.
Fandom walk.
Choose the haste stat up option ten times when leveling up.
Oh, maybe I should try with that.
I finally got 100% achievements the other day.
Let's go.
You're gaming?
More haste.
Haste.
Oh my gosh!
We have to do this one.
We have to do this because it's the... We have to haste!
We have to haste!
Some said... Is it true Fana is good?
Complete special objectives as fast as possible.
Is she good on this stage?
Fana is great for no move as well?
Oh, really?
Let's try it.
Wait, what if I don't move?
How do I get stuff though?
Okay, never mind.
I don't like it.
I'm too wiggly, you guys.
No movement challenge.
I'm too wiggly, okay?
I'm too wiggly.
I can't do it.
Too wiggly.
Literally impossible for me, okay?
Impossible.
It lasted 2 seconds.
Oh, the glasses.
Oh, I should have gotten the glasses.
Oh my gosh!
Glasses on first pull would have been so good!
I'm a fool.
I got the glasses!
Yeah, Fana's ult is very good too.
So true.
Streamer luck.
Xion can do the no movement and Crony the no damage.
Oh, okay.
Is it... wait...
There's someone who gets buffs from moving around a lot.
Who is it?
Kiara!
That's right.
Kiwawa.
Kiwawa, my beloved.
Stay away.
Kiwawa.
I need more haste.
Okay, guys.
If there's haste, we're going to try for the haste.
We're going to try for haste challenge.
I don't know if we'll complete this.
I don't know if we'll actually beat this stage.
Like if we'll get to the third stage.
It's going to take 30 minutes, but we shall try.
Obviously.
Actually, no.
I'm just going to die.
Am I an idiot?
Maybe.
I might be stupid.
Ka-ching!
Super Cha-Cha time!
Oh my gosh.
That was close.
That was so close.
Super Cha-Cha time!
Thank you guys for all the Super Chats.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
I want to do really only this stage today because Halloween time.
Whisper, whisper, whisper.
Oh, hello.
Give me a second.
Let's see what we get from here first.
Was that Peko's laugh in the background of the music?
I just heard it.
I've never heard it.
I've never heard it before.
It is.
That's so funny.
I only heard it when I went to this menu.
I now have the urge to play and hoard coins for the next update.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm trying to get ready for the next update.
Super Cha-Cha time!
Thank you, Tri-Princess.
Super Cha-Cha time.
Thank you, Star-G.
Let's see.
I'm going to...
Let's get our shield up first.
Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
Super Cha-Cha time.
I'll take it, baby.
And upgrade my shield.
We're zooming.
And awakened.
Did that say miss?
Miss.
That's my favorite sticker to use.
In Mario Party.
Miss.
We're zooming.
We're Newman.
Let's do Guardian Tree.
Yeah, there we go.
There we go.
Now we're Fauna.
Now we're Fauna-ing.
Oh, this chomp.
Get out of here!
No!
I thought I killed you.
There we go.
A Yoshi sticker.
Miss.
Oh!
Flower.
We're oo-ing now.
Okay, what do I want to...
We should probably start planning what kind of, like, collabs we want, right?
Hmm.
Maybe I will try for the, um...
Flower.
For the big...
Or...
Uh, what was it?
Um...
This with the...
With the gorilla paw, right?
All healing?
Dragon's Breath plus gorilla paw.
I haven't gotten that one before, so I actually want to try it.
So let's see if we can get it.
Let's see if we can go for it.
I'm not zooming anymore.
So sad.
Oh, she does damage when healing.
Oh, yeah, because of the tree branches.
Yeah, yeah, I get it.
I get it.
Hmm...
True.
True, true, true, true, true.
Hmm...
I was thinking about the cooldown one.
I'm not going to lie.
Uh, the idol outfit for the cooldown.
Okay.
What's a good one?
Oh, oh, wait.
Um, what's it called then?
The uber sheep would be so good then, right?
Oh, hello.
The uber sheep, like, ultra collab would be so good for Rufana then.
The horn too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe I should...
Oh, but I want to try new stuff.
Maybe I should rethink.
Okay.
Oh, we have this anyway, so we can at least...
Uh...
Oh!
Uber sheep!
Perfect.
Hahaha.
Uh,
a question for anybody that knows.
If I get the limiter, will it help me pick up these little saplings better?
Any healing item helps, yeah.
No?
Wait, some say yes.
Oh, spider cooking!
So we need spider cooking.
We need lava.
And we are on endless, so we have a little bit more time to...
For stuff.
For any additional things.
Oh yeah, we're cooking.
Ah!
Let's get the...
Let's...
I think five is the max for the glasses.
Oh!
For the glasses, right?
So...
I'll just, uh...
Asakoko injection is good for Rufana too.
If you don't pick them up, they'll come to you anyway.
Oh, really?
I think Mento's mentality on how she plays is affecting my brain.
What do you mean by that?
I run characters that just die as I walk past them.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
Die!
Die.
Die to the healer!
Oh!
Guys, we have the set up!
We have the set up!
Nice!
You could ult.
I could!
But I don't need to.
I don't need to!
Please give me like a little triple box, please.
Triple box, please.
She's cracked.
I think this is like the most setup I've ever been in like a game.
Wait, what makes my attack by horns?
Oh, horns plus full...
Oh, full meal?
Oh my gosh.
Hell yeah.
If I can get horns...
Unless I missed it.
If I did, my bad.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, just kidding.
I saw the burger on top of it and...
It looked like something new and exciting.
I should probably...
I can't decide what to...
What to level up, you guys.
Can't decide, okay?
Look how many more little saplings we got.
Full...
Full heal!
Full meal wouldn't really help with the attack.
But it would help with like, you know...
Because Fauna heals so much...
All the healing would be...
Like super intense healing, you know?
Basically.
So it's not that it would like...
Help me fight more.
It would just keep me alive longer.
Which is probably...
Good against all the Yagos at the end.
She becomes invincible!
Burning... right?
Oh...
A super shape.
Let's get this up.
I know I need to get my buckets and everything too.
I really want to get the Ultra Collab as much...
As soon as I can.
Miss!
Sparkle King!
What should we do with our...
With our tail?
What kind of...
What collab should we go with for it?
I wonder.
Oh, do flame?
Maybe.
We're not going to go with the...
We're doing an Ubersheep Ultra Collab.
So we're not going to...
Okay, here we go.
Now I...
Leave me alone!
Get out of my tree!
I haven't unlocked the sausage yet.
How do I unlock it?
Game!
You are so good!
Is it by chance or do I play a certain character?
Now it's just...
Getting the guys that we need.
Miss!
Gotta beat stage 4.
Ah!
You guys, I just beat stage...
Oh, money!
I just beat stage 3 today!
Give me a break!
I
like the...
The marking stamp.
You're doing great, Minto.
Thank you!
Replace flower?
That's exactly what I was about to do.
That is exactly what I was about to do.
You read my mind!
Are you Minto?
Would you like to become Minto?
No!
Yes!
Am I Minto?
I don't think so.
You guys may be wisps...
But I want you to stay alive.
As Naomi Hunter would say...
Live.
Just live.
But for how long, Minto?
I like this one a lot!
Usually...
Okay, like my...
I usually go with the attack up stamp.
I go with the Usa Bomb.
And then I go with Crony...
Crony Haste.
I like having the size up...
But I'll switch it out.
And I'm gonna max this.
Size increase isn't that big on Fauna.
That's fair.
You know what?
That's so fair.
Oh!
Hello!
Fauna is fast, I noticed.
Well, I guess it's because of my... nevermind.
It's because I have...
The stats up because I'm healing.
I have the effects on.
I'm taking the...
I'm taking the good stuff.
I'm taking the sapling stuff.
The green stuff.
Let's go, green girls!
Oh!
What the...
More... Oh!
You guys!
I completely forgot about the haste challenge.
I...
Did you notice that I forgot about the haste challenge, you guys?
I completely forgot about the haste challenge.
Oopsie.
Not bad.
Oh, we did it!
Guys, I forgot!
Uh-oh.
I'm like, I'm gonna do this challenge.
No haste bonuses were there though.
Oh, really?
Okay, good.
Because I was not looking.
I didn't even look a single time.
Should I enchant?
No, it's really hard to.
Um...
Uh...
Oh, here we go.
Thank you!
Alright, now we have to wait...
until level 50?
Aw, Mayim.
I'm gonna hold on to that...
anvil for now.
Chant is good.
You know what?
I lied.
Let's enchant.
Man.
Hit rate.
RIP double enchant.
It's okay.
It's all good.
No worries.
What was I going for?
I could do the bomb.
Now we can still enchant uber sheep.
So true.
Do the bomb.
You're the bomb.
Oh,
Oscar.
Stop.
Oh, Oscar.
Guys, did you see that they're making a live action Rugrats?
Except the Rugrat babies are all gonna be in 3D.
And I think negative people on this planet Earth have asked for this.
Negative people want the Rugrats live action movie.
I swear.
Nobody wants this.
Why is it happening?
It's gonna look so awful and terrible.
Minto, take that back.
I can't.
If I learn this, you also have to learn this.
I'm sorry.
Nobody wants this.
Negative people.
I used to watch Rugrats and I remember not enjoying it.
I would be like, why?
Am I watching this?
Oh, wait.
I can't enchant the uber cheap.
Uber cheap.
Uber sheep.
Never mind.
I guess we can...
Oh, well.
Wait.
Nobody wants the Rugrats movie.
Jack Black is Tommy Pickles.
I am Tommy.
Big if real.
I've never seen the ANS curse.
Fires curse energy in front.
On hit, there is a chance to spread another curse towards another nearby target.
A baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
People used to say I sound like Phil and Lou.
I'm so offended by that.
EN curse but spider cooking.
Oh, but I already use the spider cooking.
A baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
Don't do that.
I was just trying to stay in place.
I don't understand the no moving challenge when it comes to things that drop on top of you.
Do you just have to become super tanky and really good at healing?
Is it just all about survival and less about attack?
Survival and knockback.
Asana's good for you.
Yeah, I can believe that.
Upgrade 3.
Just thinking that.
We're taking damage actually.
What the hell?
Who are you?
Oh my god, I'm taking damage.
Oh my god, I'm taking a lot of damage.
Not
on my watch.
Hmm.
I don't understand it though.
Gaining 15 max HP for every 6 points of total max HP.
Increased damage.
3 is good on Fauna?
I don't really understand it.
So you get more HP, but what do you mean every 6 points of total max?
Oh, so like if you don't take damage?
More HP, more damage.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Hmm.
I mean we do heal a lot because of being Fauna.
We'll try it.
Oh my goodness.
Woo!
Come here little stamp.
Oh, oh.
There we go.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
What else am I going to do for Halloween?
I want to build a...
Maybe like a... Oh!
Aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, aye.
Quit your healing!
Did I kill him?
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
I need health.
Give me health!
Um...
I want to build like a haunted gingerbread house.
I've seen them at like the store.
Like kits for it, you know?
So I thought about maybe doing something like that.
I don't know.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, I don't have it.
It baited me.
I thought I had the... I thought I finished it.
Wow!
Joy!
Thanks for the 50!
Thanks for the pink!
Whammy water!
Okay.
Why not?
Whammy water.
I'll take some whammy water.
It is water, right guys?
It's water.
Because boy am I thirsty.
If I chug it, I'll be fine, right?
I'm really thirsty.
I'm really dehydrated right now.
Please, I'm so thirsty.
Just give me some whammy water.
Gamer juice.
Okay, we're almost to level...
We're almost to...
Oh gosh!
We're almost to level 50 though.
So we'll get that...
We'll get that...
hammer soon.
Stop healing!
There's only death here.
I like how it's like save the fans and I keep saying that I'm killing them.
Mommy Mint needs her go-go juice.
Who else is watching while in the shower?
You super chatted while in the shower.
Okay.
We're saving them by putting them out of their misery, right?
Little fans.
It's almost over.
Everything...
You'll be fine.
You'll be safe after this.
You can rest now, little fans.
You can rest
now, little fans.
Yippee!
What should we do with our whammy water?
I want to start freezing people.
Wait, what's the one with the...
Wait, I can't remember.
Hold on.
The penlight.
Drink it.
Or wait, should I do the BL book with it?
Wait, which one...
Does the BL book also freeze?
Oh, it does have that effect too?
Okay, then we'll go with the BL book.
I could choose either one!
The world is my oyster!
Okay.
Ask and you shall receive.
Accepting the gotcha.
Then we hate you.
Yeah!
There it is, baby!
Oh, chocolate aberration!
Oh, and I need it.
Because I'm dying currently.
I'm currently...
I'm currently really dying.
I'm currently not having a good time.
I'm currently not dodging anything, actually.
I'm currently...
Having a tough time at the moment.
Um...
Oh, gosh.
Oh!
I'm currently...
Not doing so hot.
I'm currently unable to see anything that's going on on the screen.
Stop shooting at me, please.
I'm currently going through it, yeah.
I'm currently...
The number isn't going down.
Because we're just that good.
We're just that good, baby.
It's fine.
Oh.
Back into the green circle.
Green woman in the green circle.
Why is green so unpopular with VTubers, I wonder?
I know blue is nice, but like...
You could be like me and be a mix of both.
Oh, hello.
I didn't even notice.
Blue is so popular with VTubers, I feel.
Blue and like purple.
And things like that, you know?
We love green woman.
Yippee!
Oh, no.
No, sorry.
I don't want that.
No.
I think I'm good.
In fact, I'm just gonna like sit here.
Oh.
I'm gonna sell that.
Don't ask me why.
I use my ult.
It's because...
I felt it in my bones.
Or something.
I don't know.
Huh.
Whammy Water Max.
Oh.
Ha.
Okay.
Meow.
Oh.
My ghost about...
Oh, yeah.
What bones?
Hahaha.
My phantom bones.
It's kind of like, you know?
It's a phantom pain.
I have phantom bones.
I feel like I could still feel my bones.
It's just silly ghost things.
Gosh, what if I still have bones?
Because I know what having bones used to feel like.
I think.
I might be a pile of goo now, but...
I don't know.
I'm still stiff.
Hahaha.
Probably.
Having bones sucks.
What?
Okay.
Come on.
You're going to say that to me?
I wish I had bones right now.
I think.
Wow.
Don't take your bones for granted, you guys.
Do you like your VTubers boneless or with bones?
How do you prefer your VTubers?
Boneless VTubers with bones?
How do you prefer?
Oh my gosh.
Joy, thank you for the VTuber gift.
Thank you.
In the shower.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
The screams are so scary.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, I'm trapped on a wall.
Oh, I'm trapped again.
I'm trying to get out of here.
I'm trying to leave.
Please excuse me.
Please leave.
Let me.
Please let me leave.
Please let me leave!
Goodness gracious.
Yippee!
I like to just get away from the Touhou stuff.
My days of Touhou are over.
I did my crimes.
I did my times, okay?
I don't have to Danmaku any longer.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Why do I become so slow?
Why am I so heavy?
Crimes, crimes, crimes.
I've run out of saplings.
Please, little saplings, come back to me!
Oh.
What should we go with, you guys?
I have like...
Nothing.
I have so much room.
And curse?
Oh yeah, I haven't tried it.
Let's go for it.
Where is it?
What's it doing?
What's the curse?
What is it happening?
Where's the curse?
What's going on?
Oh, we did it.
Yippee!
Ellie, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Look for purple.
Oh, okay.
Awesome.
Okay.
Everybody, give me more saplings.
Die for me.
Die for sapling.
Die...
Oh.
Die to become sapling.
I can barely see it.
I can't see it.
I can't see it at all.
Maybe I do see it.
I'm not sure actually.
I can't tell.
Oh my goodness.
Not ready to ult yet.
Not yet.
What is it?
Ian's curse plus board is what people say.
Oh, I see the purple.
I'm not ready to ult yet.
Not yet.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Yes, the board.
Or tears.
Okay.
Good to know.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh, I keep eating these Danmaku, for real.
Am I okay?
When I said my Touhou days are done...
Curseball is not... Not tears.
Oh, okay.
Don't do tears.
But I want to complete my list!
I will not do...
I will resist.
Okay.
Now I can collect everything without worry.
Yes.
You can't touch me.
Okay, now you can touch me.
I'm scared about that.
Frozen!
Who told me that the books freeze?
They haven't frozen anything.
Reroll for board.
Oh, I should have, right?
Oh, they slow.
I see, I see.
Swap one?
No, I think I'm going to keep it.
I do like having this one.
Freeze is just the sake.
Ah, you made a mistake!
Okay, well, it's alright.
I'll just sell it.
Reroll!
Ah!
Perfect.
Guys, we got it.
We got it, baby.
We're so good, baby.
We're good, baby.
Oh, we're good, babe.
We're good.
We're alright, baby.
Maybe not good.
Maybe good is a big word, baby.
Babycore, thanks for the gift.
You got this, boss, baby.
I can't even remember what...
Burr...
Board plus curse...
The burst.
Board plus curses.
Well, you will see.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
As long as I live!
You can't kill me if I'm already dead.
Miss.
Did I max?
Okay.
We maxed out curse, so...
Do-do-do-do.
Oh,
they're getting really close up on me.
It's scaring me a little bit.
They're getting really close on me, guys.
Oh, I just dropped.
Oh!
Nice.
Getting bored.
Almost there.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I keep eating.
Ganmaku.
Always.
But they're like... they're forbidden!
Haichu or something.
I don't know.
They look so delicious.
So curious.
I don't even see the board.
Is it even doing anything?
I don't even know.
Oh yeah!
Let's grab the horns!
What's wrong with me?
Oh my gosh.
Let's grab the horns while we have them.
I should have grabbed them from long ago.
Oh my god.
Horns go... I've been meaning to get them for so long.
There we go.
There we go!
Now, now, now, now.
Now Fauna should be much in a better situation.
True Fauna strats.
I was so... my mind was so one track on like... you know.
Bandage as well?
Okay.
Well, if we see the bandage, we'll get that.
We have lots of space, so...
There's not enough like... pushback, whatever it's called.
Okay.
Alright.
Where is...
Get out of my way!
Don't bite the hand that feeds you if it's holding a knife.
Let's see what happens.
Holy...
Holy cow!
Holy cow, holy cow.
Holy cow.
I'm gonna reroll for...
Bandage.
I'm just hiding between, I think Axe...
Tears?
But they're not...
These ones are... are... enchanted.
These ones aren't... aren't... enchanted.
Ubersheep?
I already have Ubersheep.
It's a... I already... I already have Ubersheep.
Hahaha.
Joy, thanks for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Potato?
Okay.
It's best if not... Okay.
We'll try... I'll try... I'll do the potato.
Oh my goodness.
Wow!
Come on!
Give me money.
Despite not being a coin run, it's alright.
We're not a coin.
I'll take it, you know?
Sheesh.
Oh my goodness.
I think it's so close up on me.
It's...
Ah!
Oh!
I got the bandage.
Increase max HP by 10.
After being hit, heal 10%.
Everything's...
Oh, okay.
I mean, I'm getting hit a lot, so...
Probably should take it, huh?
I'm getting hit, like, a lot.
So, I think...
I still have space, so if there's anything else that I want to get...
No!
I just can't seem to...
I can't... Oh, they're just, like, literally on top of me.
These fans are crazy!
Oh my god.
Guys.
Time to ult.
They're just on top of me!
No!
Guys, I don't know if I'm going to make it to 30 minutes.
Oh, I don't think I'm going to make it to 30 minutes.
I don't think I'm going to make it to 30 minutes.
Feather!
We could feather.
We get a revive.
That's so true.
I once got the...
I once got, like, the super feather.
Out of a pull.
It was so good.
I wish I could get a meal.
I could reroll for the meal.
What if I don't get it, though?
Super feather is so good.
What do you mean meal wouldn't help?
You guys, it's double healing!
Look at me!
I'm taking damage like crazy!
Hmm...
Feather should take you to 30.
Alright, let's try it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
I don't know about that, guys!
I don't know!
I don't know about that!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm full health.
How'd that happen?
More feather!
I want the two revives!
Oh, gosh!
I don't care.
Maybe...
I don't know, though.
I don't know.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know what to do.
Four for HP?
True.
Oh, my God.
I like how it's just like, by the way, you're taking damage.
You're taking damage, by the way.
Oh, my gosh!
This sucks.
This sucks!
Will I get the two revives now?
Oh, my God.
They just come up on me.
They're so fast!
Get away from me!
Please!
Stay away!
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it to 30 minutes.
Oh, man!
We got so close, though.
We got so close.
I'm just gonna leave.
Bye!
Just run.
Just run, Fauna.
Run.
Run away.
Run, Fauna!
Run!
Fauna, run!
Run, Fauna!
Just heal when you can, Fauna!
Run!
Run, Fauna!
Fauna, run!
Just get out of there!
Run, Fauna!
Don't meow!
Oh, my ult's better!
Oh!
Okay.
My health went down so fast, I didn't even have a chance to ult.
Oh, my health's better!
15 seconds left, baby!
Baby!
Oh, my god!
Hello, greed!
At
the very end is hilarious.
I know.
A bit late, huh?
It's okay.
Okay, run, Fauna.
Run.
Fauna, run.
Run, Fauna.
Run.
Go this way, Fauna.
Oh, shit.
Oh!
You guys!
We did it!
We
made it!
We had to cheese that... well, not cheese.
We had to like really... we kind of like had to cheat that a little bit, but...
We made it!
My high score.
I'm number 500 plus.
No!
Yay!
Kiwawa saved the day.
Thank you my beloved chicken waifu.
I love you.
Check daily?
Oh, let's see.
Mom.
Mom, look at me.
I'm on the leaderboard.
Sorry, investigator.
That's me!
Number one!
I would like to thank my
Kiwawa.
And Uber.
For delivering me hamburgers.
Okay, I'm over it.
Yay!
Thank you!
Thank you guys for playing Hollow Cure again with me.
As you can tell, I'm a little bit obsessed.
Because I've just been playing it quite a bit.
So, I can buy more upgrades.
Thanks for the coin!
It's so much fun.
Oh my gosh.
But, yeah.
I said before.
I was like, I won't play again until the new update.
I don't want to say that will be the case.
But...
I do want to do some more grinding before I play again.
It really just depends on how busy I am.
I couldn't obviously play while I was in Japan.
I didn't even have my computer, so...
Just 500 coins short of an HP upgrade?
Oh, you're right!
Yeah.
Oh well.
There's still Hollow House 2.
Let's fish, like, just a little bit.
Let's go as the goat Kiwala.
Mick...
Mickey!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Shrimp.
Shrimp 2.
What if I just did a whole stream of Justice?
Would you guys be okay with that?
Yeah.
This puss-yapping?
Okay.
We'll play.
It makes me want to fall asleep, though.
In a good way.
There's an achievement for getting a ton in a row.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, no!
Oh, my goodness!
Tuna!
Always fun to watch...
...you gaming...
...looking forward to your performance at Off-Season Live tonight.
I'll see you there!
See you there!
Fully cooler!
Okay, one more.
Shrimp.
One more.
Good luck on the concert.
Thank you!
I'm gonna go...
...race my voice.
They're also gonna give me, like, a little tour around the boat, so I'm very excited.
I'm excited.
Ah!
What's your number one Wawa costume?
What the?
Three tuna?
I'll take that.
How'd you do that?
My number one Wawa costume...
...probably would've been the summer costume...
...until...
...her, like, night outfit.
I love that one so much.
So good.
So, so good.
The night one is so awesome.
I love the hair so much.
Me too!
Me too, me too!
Oh, the exercise outfit?
Oh my gosh.
That's...
Okay.
The exercise outfit?
That was like...
Everybody's seen the 3D.
Fan 3D.
I'm so glad that she could use that.
That she could use that, like, fan 3D.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I feel like with some, like, corporate companies, they can be kind of strict on like, what type of fan models are allowed and stuff like that.
So that's why you see, like, a lot of corporate YouTubers using, like, chibi 3D models and stuff in, like, streams and things.
So...
So I'm really happy that they allowed her to use it.
Yeah...
Secretly Management wanted to see her in it too.
I don't know how it works in the video.
I know for, like...
Maybe other companies?
Umm...
It's like a special...
It's like a...
You have to, like, earn the...
The...
Other outfits in 3D.
Kind of deal.
Have fun on the boat tonight!
Looking forward to the casino on the next update.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
Commander Church!
Welcome to Mambo Chef!
Thank you!
Yeah, so...
If they're just like... If you, like, want to use a different outfit for...
For...
A 3D...
Uh...
You either pay or earn it.
So...
You know...
They don't want...
Other models looking too similar to...
The real outfit... The real thing.
Unless it's chibi, you know?
For some... From what I've heard.
From what I've heard.
Hmm...
So...
Yeah...
Umm...
Yeah!
Allegedly.
A new update was announced.
Oh, they're working on it.
I don't think it was...
Announced when it will be out.
Sorry if my...
Title is a little misleading.
Maybe it's a little clickbaity.
So...
Yeah...
Umm...
Legally.
Allegedly.
Allegedly...
Not legally.
Oh...
Allegedly...
What's other... What's another word to not get me sued?
In Minecraft.
There we go.
Okay, so next update is expected end of October...
Start of November.
So we shall see.
Hypothetically.
That's the word I...
Not legally.
Hypothetically was the word I was...
I was thinking of.
Yes, yes, yes.
Well, cool.
Thank you guys again.
If I see you at the concert tonight, I will see you.
And if not...
Tomorrow I am playing Metal Gear.
Metal Gear Metal Gear.
If I see you there, I'll see you there.
If not...
I'll see you in the next scene.
Umm...
Yeah.
Have fun at the concert.
Thank you!
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you for helping me out.
I really really appreciate it.
And I really appreciate you guys being so respectful in the chat.
Maybe you weren't respectful.
I just was gaming and I couldn't see you guys calling me an idiot.
I don't know.
But from what I saw, you guys were very good.
So thank you.
And...
You're like stupid VTuber.
Not listening to my advice.
While I'm...
Oh my gosh.
You know what I'm just gonna do?
I'm just gonna have... I'm gonna be like a Twitch streamer and I'm gonna have don't know text to speech.
That way...
That way you can yell your advice for real and I'll hear it.
Okay?
Oh my gosh.
Joy, thank you for the pic.
Thank you.
VTuber, why?
You did great.
Thank you.
Rock that boat VTuber.
My setlist is very...
boat slash mech kind of war themed.
Right?
I was like I'm on a boat.
I have to sing.
Boat songs.
Right?
Maybe some Kankole.
I don't know.
If you're there.
Then you'll hear.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
Castaway from Barak Yargis.
Castaways.
We are castaways.
Da da da.
I don't remember.
I don't remember the words actually.
Minto sea shanty.
Yo ho.
Ba ba ba.
Boys love da ba.
Peavos.
Sins and cellars.
Never shall we.
Oh thieves and beggars.
My bad.
Never shall we die.
I don't know the words at all.
Okay.
Ochu.
Minto.
For real.
Itadakimasu everybody.
Thank you so much.
I will see you.
Next time.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
Oh wait a second.
I forgot to set something up.
I have to spam my 3.0 everywhere.
So everybody sees.
So I have to have it on my intro.
I have to have it on my outro.
I have to have it all over the place.
So you guys remember to come on October 31st.
To see my new model.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ochu.
Minto.
Bye bye.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Actually I'm just gonna like.
Hold on.
I'm gonna do some some What's it called?
Here.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's do this instead.
Instead of just having it there.
Let's have my whole menu.
Let's have the menu up baby.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot to put my gamer subs in.
Oh my gosh you guys.
I have to put in my gamer subs.
I got a package today of gamer subs.
I have more.
I started giving my gamer subs to my friends.
Cause I'm like.
Oh my gosh.
They send me way a lot of gamer subs.
They send me a lot.
They send me so much stuff.
So much.
Wait.
Is it in there?
There we go.
Use code Boomer.
Oh.
It's gone now.
What flavor?
They sent me the gloomy bear flavor.
They sent me Aura GX.
The internet browser has a flavor too?
They sent me one other one.
I don't remember.
What about the Hoppy?
Let's put the Hoppy code in there too.
Yeah.
I need a better picture of the Hoppy code.
I'm gonna contact them.
Oh.
Opera is Opera GX.
Sorry.
The browser is Opera.
Yeah.
Opera.
Then Aura is their Vtuber.
Yeah.
Don't forget to use code Boomer for 10% off gamer stuff.
You guys.
I haven't forgotten about the codes that they give me.
Remember for my for my anniversary.
They gave me codes.
I just have been so busy.
I literally haven't even been able to get the raffle set up.
I literally still have those though.
They don't expire.
They told me.
I just have to set everything up.
I'm so.
I'm so bad.
I'm sorry.
But I still have them.
Maybe I'll use them for my 3.0.
I don't know.
They even asked me if I wanted more for my birthday.
And I was like.
Oh my god.
Hi.
I haven't even used the one that you gave me first.
Luckily.
I was like thinking about it.
I was like.
This is why I don't like.
You know.
I would feel way worse if like.
If like.
The people have one.
And then I just forgot to send it to them.
You know.
But I don't forget.
I just get busy.
This is why I'm like.
You know.
For like everything.
Like my merch and everything.
I'm like.
I won't accept any money until I am 100% confident that I have everything.
All my ducks in a row.
So that there are no delays.
Because.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not gonna take your money or anything.
And then you'll be waiting forever.
So.
Can I post in chat yet?
Yeah.
Shut up and take my money.
No.
She's still going.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm done.
Alright.
You want me to shut up.
I got you.
Okay.
I'll shut up.
Alright.
I'll stop talking.
Like.
Right.
Bye.
.